all right welcome everybody our last
show before the thanksgiving break a few
disclaimers before we start
i'm feeling fine i appreciate the
messages of concern
continuing to pour in uh i sound
different this week if you're listening
because i'm in a different location
different microphone i look different
because of different lighting and i'm
sort of in front of a weird window
but i'm fine it's just the lighting i've
not gone pale
or red or whatever people are worried
about i appreciate the concern i'm
feeling fine
heading into the thanksgiving holiday
hopefully
safely and a few things i want to talk
about with you
today uh before we go on our brief
thanksgiving break
first of all uh now that donald trump
has come as close as he is likely to get
to conceding this election to joe biden
the transition has officially started
even though it had started already but
now it's
really started we must focus
on the two georgia senate runoffs
as the primary focus of the next
roughly eight weeks and well actually
it's eight weeks until biden is sworn in
uh but it's only about six weeks until
these runoffs on january 5th
there will be two runoff elections in
georgia
which will determine do republicans
control the senate
for joe biden's first two years or do
democrats control the senate for joe
biden's first two years
one race is incumbent republican david
perdue
versus democratic challenger john ossoff
the other race is republican incumbent
kelly loffler one of the most corrupt
senators in the senate
versus democratic challenger rafael
warnock
these will be tough races but they are
winnable races and we have to understand
it'll be tough but we can win both ideas
we can hold at the same time the loffler
versus warnock race is reportedly a one
point race some polls say it's loffler
plus one
others say it's warnock plus one what
does this mean
i'll wait you know i don't have to tell
you everybody
who votes in georgia must vote legal
votes obviously
um it's basically a tie the other race
perdue versus assaf
also right in there the late we have we
have uh only one recent poll from last
week which says it's 49.49
previous polls showed that purdue uh was
a little bit ahead by three or even as
many as four points
it's a statistical tie right now they
are uphill battles
the path forward is putting all of our
effort
into these races anybody who wants to
phone bank can phone bank
donate if you can afford to pandemic
safe door knocking is being organized in
georgia if you are
in georgia uh voter registration
including the work of stacy abrams could
be the difference maker here her work
has been unbelievable
and on the other side there this is this
is more funny because it's so
self-defeating than anything else
there are some republicans that are so
mad at
trump uh and other republicans
for i guess not fighting more to steal
the presidency from joe biden
that there are some republicans in
georgia saying
boycott the senate runoff just don't go
and vote
and to them i say what a great idea i
hope that that's exactly what you do
help us defeat those incumbent
republicans
uh uh we we really cannot overstate the
importance
of these races if assaf and warnock
win it's 50 50 in the senate that makes
kamala harris the deciding vote
this means tax reform might be done
this means health care expansion might
be done
maybe infrastructure and more now
they will all be battles understand that
even with control of the senate you will
still be up against the more
centrist wing of the democratic party
but
these become battles worth fighting i
believe and i know some people say david
you're being too pessimistic
i believe that without the senate none
of this gets done i just don't see how
you do tax reform and health care
expansion
and infrastructure the way joe biden
wants to do it focused on clean green
energy
i don't see how you do it without the
senate um if if
the democrats are not able to win those
two seats
joe biden will be relegated to governing
at least for two years
essentially by executive order on all
but the most
uncontroversial things and remarkably
little will get done
in terms of big legislation so this is
where the focus has to be
and meanwhile donald trump really seems
to be running out of gas let's discuss
that next
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing and
magic spoon now lets you create your own
customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo code pacman to get free
shipping
the link is right underneath this video